ça met un petit coup quand même madame
le maire de paris sheeran merci d'être
présente ça me touche beaucoup
cher patrick ollier norris luministe
parler du grand paris pour moi c'est une
grande émotion parce que lorsque nous
avons lancé le grand paris les
sceptiques les critiques nées en france
les moqueurs étaient beaucoup plus
importants que ceux qui y croyaient
on mettait ce grand paris sous le compte
d'un président de la république
hyperactif qui aimait parler mais sur un
projet qui ne verrait jamais le jour
moi j'étais sur ce projet et d'efforts
hors historique et au fond c'est
peut-être la chose la plus importante de
mon quinquennat
ja christian qui reste aujourd'hui c'est
d'ailleurs toute la difficulté de la
politique
les agendas des responsables politiques
sont bondées du matin au soir pour une
activité dont il ne restera rien
absolument rien vous arriver chez nous
le soir
exténué vous avez vu 90 personnes
avaient fait 8 déplacements
vous avez vraiment le sentiment de faire
votre travail et deux jours après il ne
reste rien donc c'est une grande preuve
de modestie d'ailleurs on ne sait pas ce
qui dans son mandat pas résisté à
l'épreuve du temps donc à l'épreuve de
l'histoire ce qui comptera vraiment où
ce qui était simplement de l'actualité
l'actualité c'est rien l ai remplacé
parce qu'il viendrait le grand paris
c'est le contraire de l'actualité le
grand paris c'est une vision
alors pourquoi le le grand paris d'abord
quand j'en parle la première fois en
2007 c'est parce que je suis frappé que
grosso modo depuis les années 60 et paul
delouvrier et c'est une critique de
personnes à 1 surtout patrick y avait eu
un seul véritable grands chantiers
structurants non seulement à paris mais
en région parisienne par pardon de dire
ça bien sûr il ya des mères
l'humeur paris qui ont fait des choses
je dis pas ça ne regarde de la
conurbation de 8 à 12 millions de
personnes selon le calcul que l'on fait
il n'y avait plus eu de gestes
structurants et c'était quand même
intéressant de voir une france hyper
centralisé autour de son coeur et sa
capitale qui était un désert en termes
de nouvelles infrastructures ou de
chantier de grandes ambitions qui
dépassait les frontières d'une commune
fussent les frontières de paris je
pensais que c'était une erreur
historique et toutes personnes qui
voyagent voyait shanghai voyait dehors
voyait dubaï
voyez toutes les grandes capitales en
australie ou ailleurs se transformer
avec des gestes architecturaux majeur
est chez nous dans ces capitales paris
qui est la plus belle ville du monde
dans cette agglomération parisienne
censé tirer le pays christian ne vais
rien et d'ailleurs s'il y avait rien
c'était pas pour des raisons étranges
c'est parce qu'ils ne pouvaient rien à
voir car le pouvoir était si explosé en
tant de responsables différents et les
réglementations si rigide que personne
ne pouvait rien faire
c'est pas qu'on avait décidé de rien
faire c'est que c'était au sens littéral
inhumain de faire quelque chose en tout
cas à l'horizon d'un mandat fut tina
mandat municipal
je me suis dit mais c'est fou donc on va
essayer de bouger cela puis la crise est
arrivée la première la crise
stratosphérique de 2008
hélas au sortir de la crise je me suis
dit soit on meurt tous sont réagi mais
on peut pas se retrouver
dans la situation de profonde dépression
dans laquelle nous nous trouvions à ce
moment là la dette avait explosé déjà la
crise de confiance était massive
l'économie était exemple et le monde
entier tu es stupéfait du choc qu'il
avait reçu que l'économie mondiale avait
reçu sans d'ailleurs savoir d'où venait
ce choc parce que tout le monde parle de
lehman brothers mais enfin c'était
lehman brothers
l'allumette ne comprenait pas pourquoi
les choses s'étaient passées ainsi
et je me suis dit à ce moment là c'est
le temps non seulement d'aller sur le
comparer mais de lui donner une ampleur
une vitesse une existence parce que la
crise est toujours une opportunité et
c'est la première idée que je voudrais
défendre devant vous je crois aux grands
projets il n'y a pas un pays qui puisse
construire son avenir son grand projet
est d'ailleurs il ya des témoins dans la
salle jerram
faisant fi de nos différences politiques
j'ai toujours soutenu la tête au
triangle y compris contre l'avis de
certains de mes propres amis parce que
je trouvais que ce grand geste
architectural un endroit dont on ne peut
pas dire qu'il était le plus beau de
paris avec vue imprenable sur le
périphérique
je pense que ce qui était l'erreur c'est
de rien faire pas de faire cela
j'ai été pour cela que vous savez très
bien que ce roland garros et sur tant
d'autres sujets
je pense profondément qu'il n'ya pas de
ville prospère de pays prospère de ville
heureuse de pays heureux sans proposer à
la population de se mobiliser autour
d'un projet plus grand qu'eux mêmes
c'est pas simplement une question d'ego
c'est pas simplement une question
d'ambition mal placés chacun besoin
d'espérer et je vous faire une
révélation
on n'espère pas sur ce qui est tout
petit
on espère sur ce qui est plus grand on
espère sur ce qui est plus large
on espère sur ce qui fait rêver non pas
simplement chose qui est le quotidien
commun lassant ennuyeux et d'ailleurs
vous les élus si vous êtes élu c'est
bien sûr pour gérer le quotidien
mais c'est d'abord pour porter une
vision de la ville ou du territoire vous
conduisez or cette vision forcément elle
va aller au delà de vous au-delà de
votre mandat au delà de votre personne
il n'y a pas d'avenir pour la france son
grand projet et j'en tire d'ailleurs la
conclusion que le grand paris pour voir
son futur
il s'appelle le grand marseille il
s'appelle le grand lyon il s'appelle le
grand lille
dans mon esprit le grand paris n'a pas
vocation n'est ce pas christian à être
simplement l'avenir de la capitale c'est
un modèle c'est qu'une ambition
si aujourd'hui je devais les
propositions je dirais qu'il est capital
qu'on fasse le grand marseille avec un
thème que je propose faire de marseille
la capitale culturelle de la
méditerranée c'est le moment j'ai voulu
[Musique]
le mucem à marseille qui est un succès
en pleine crise personne n'en voulait et
bien la culture l'art doit pas être
victime de la crise puisqu'ils sont la
réponse à la crise l'avenir de marseille
c'est ça et le grand paris cher patrick
chirac a besoin de se nourrir de projets
aussi ambitieux alors dit motion
d'autres villes
le grand lyon notamment dans sa liaison
avec l'italie le grand lille avec le
cndd nord et donc je voulais que
derrière le grand paris floris d'autres
grandes ambitions pour des villes qui ne
sont pas la capitale de la france mais
qui ont un rôle moteur pour l'économie
française
c'est absolument essentiel et
aujourd'hui je voudrais qu'on propose à
marseille de construire trois nouveaux
musées des salles de spectacles des
lieux de rencontre et des changes qui
irrigueront toute la méditerranée
je voudrais d'ailleurs dire une autre
chose le grand paris n'est pas une
dépense c'est une recette si on voit le
grand paris comme une dépense on fera
jamais rien si on attend d'avoir
l'argent ou faire un investissement
vous pouvez attendre longtemps kaya
jamais d'argent et je vous dire une
chose très simple que je crois prouve
plus profond de moi même
c'est le projet qui fait l'argent c'est
pas l'argent qui fait le projet
réfléchir à ça c'est plus intelligent
qu'il n'y paraît au premier abord je
reconnais oui malgré le masque je vois
votre oeil pétillant
et séparées pour les entreprises comme
pour les collectivités jamais à l'argent
jamais on arrive avec une réserve en
disant dis donc il ya ça a dépensé
qu'est ce qu'on fait les amis l'économie
du grand paris du grand marseille du
grand lyon
ce que vous voulez c'est créer les
conditions de la croissance de demain
je voudrais d'ailleurs à ce moment de
mon propos dire une chose je suis frappé
de voir la faiblesse de la réflexion en
théorie économique avec cet élément
majeur et d'une brutalité immense dune
valeur monétaire à zéro voire négative
on ne peut pas réfléchir à la question
de la dette avec une monnaie qui a une
valeur négative une valeur zéro comme on
y réfléchissait à l'époque ma pauvre
mère s'endetter à 17% pour acheter son
propre appartement
pour la première fois on assiste quelque
chose d'assez insensé certains déposent
de l'argent et paient pour que des
banques gagne c'est un chant garde cet
argent donc s'il ya bien un moment où la
question de l'endettement ne devrait pas
se poser c'est maintenant excusez moi un
viol idées au président de la tribune
on va pas poser la question de temps
d'été quand l'argent est cher la
question de l'endettement c'est quand sa
valeur est à 0 à wendy oui mais en
disant ça tu es responsable parce que il
va falloir rembourser ses dettes certes
mais mes chers amis pour la rembourser
il faut avec cet argent faire des
investissements qui créeront les
conditions de la croissance qui
permettront demain de rembourser la
dette
car si vous empruntez et vous faites par
ses investissements
demain dont trois ans dans quatre ans
dans cinq ans je ne sais pas quand les
taux d'intérêt remonteront si vous
n'avez pas créé les nouveaux moteurs de
la croissance nous ne rembourserait pas
votre dette
est-ce que je me fais comprendre que la
question n'est pas n'est plus
le montant de la dette la question et
lusage de la dette
je reconnais c'est très élaborés et
c'est pas du tout à la mode mais j'y
crois
preuve en est membre peu importe que
vous soyez à 100% à 180% contre le japon
est à près de 200% de dette par rapport
à son pic
je ne crois pas que ça empêche le japon
d'être la deuxième économie du monde
donc tout l'argent levé par la société
du grand paris pour investir c'est cet
argent qui permettra de rembourser la
dette demain parce que vous créer les
conditions d'une croissance et au fond
c'est beaucoup plus dangereux est
beaucoup plus cher de ne rien faire et
d'attendre que le ciel vous tombe sur la
tête que de mettre en oeuvre un projet
de cette nature
la troisième chose c'est que enfin je
suis désolé c'est peut-être décousu ce
que je dis mais sur un sujet pareil je
ne veux pas faire un discours
je vais essayer de faire partager une
conviction je suis pas là pour vous
séduire
je suis là pour vous convaincre faut
choisir séduction conviction j'ai choisi
conviction à partir de ce moment là ce
qui trahit l'esprit du grand paris c'est
de limiter sur nos missions
parce que si vous faites un moyen grand
paris où un petit grand paris vous aurez
tous les inconvénients des dépenses et
aucun des avantages de l'ambition et
c'est très important
chacun on va dire c'est plus facile pour
vous parce que maintenant vous voyez ça
du port de la lune non le grand paris
c'est fait pour être large pour être
vaste
si vous le réduisent et vous vous
trompez et vous trahissez la philosophie
du grand paris et le grand paris ne
répondra pas aux attentes de la
population et des élus
donc à chaque fois qu'on me dit non non
si trop grand faim me dis là rien
compris alors il ya deux manières de
réduire l'ambition du grand paris
la première elle est évidente aux coupes
des projets il m'arrive de voir parfois
ça commence et la seconde est plus
pernicieuse mettrait dans chose
elle est dans l'étalement du calendrier
parce que c'est trop facile vous étalez
le calendrier
à l'arrivée vous mettez 25 ans à faire
ce qui pourrait en mettre 5
et si vous avez envie d'être convaincu
prenez un billet d'avion pour aller
rejoindre maurice leroy aller à moscou
et vous verrez comment on transforme une
ville par le grand moscou avec une
rapidité stupéfiante tup en train
d'expliquer que monsieur poutine estime
jazz dit simplement regarder les faits
le reste chacun peut avoir sur l'opinion
mais quitte à investir dans le grand
paris il faut investir tout de suite il
faut investir massivement et il faut
investir rapidement
d'ailleurs qu'est-ce que vous attendez
que les taux d'intérêts remonte un jour
pour qu'on vous dise à ce moment là que
c'est trop tard vous pouvez pas emprunté
vous pouvez pas financé ça n'a pas de
sens sans compter la lassitude des
populations à partir de ce moment là et
il est évident je le dis depuis le début
et c'est déconnecté de toute arrière
pensée politique vraiment que je n'ai
plus mes que par exemple il faut de
toute urgence engagé le tgv le havre
paris
parce que le havre c'est le port de
paris je ne porte pas du tout atteint ce
n'est pas que le porte paris
naturellement bien sûr vous faire très
attention à ce qu'on dit non mais quand
vous voyez le blason de paris et un
bateau non c'est pas simplement la scène
ayant la scène et se jette quelque part
c'est c'est quand même pas une énormité
que de dire cela
or le port de paris
l'alimentation la fourniture
marchandises de toutes la commémoration
parisienne la grande région parisienne
ça vient du havre donc faire le tgv le
havre paris c'est un investissement
majeur mais je pense la même chose quand
j'ai voulu le tgv paris bordeaux qui met
bordeaux à 2h15 de paris et qui a fait
augmenter exploser le prix de
l'immobilier
mais pour moi ce n'est pas la fin je me
souviens des batailles homériques avec
madame royal où monsieur juppé parce
qu'il manquait 20 millions j'ai dit ça
mais totalement égal parce que excusez
moi maintenant que le tgv fait qui va me
dire que j'ai pris un risque parce qu'il
manquait 20 millions il ya quelqu'un qui
va se plaindre du tgv mais moi je vous
dis une chose le tgv doit aller jusqu'à
toulouse
c'est insensé que le toulouse est pas le
tgv le tgv doit aller jusqu'à la
frontière avec l'espagne et jusqu'à
biarritz d'ailleurs si on a vraiment une
conscience écologique et qu'on me
diminuer le trafic aérien
qu'est ce qu'on a on n'a qu'à dire tout
simplement qu'elle tgv et à ce moment là
vous aurez pas besoin de la navette
toulouse paris puisqu'elle tgv comme
vous n'avez plus besoin de la navette
bordeaux-paris fin puisqu'il ya le dgd
de la même façon pour elle moi j'avais
arrêté le tgv à arrènes matin il faut
certainement possible jusqu'à brest à
web dire me sort du sujet non c'est le
même sujet est-ce que nous sommes les
gestionnaires du quotidien
quand nous sommes élus ou est-ce que
nous sommes porteurs d'une vision pour
l'aménagement du pays
on me disait
je suis très européen chacun sait des
fous strasbourg est la capitale de
l'europe parfait c'était tellement la
capitale de l'europe qui manquait 125 km
pour le tgv
donc on pouvait pas aller à strasbourg
les deux avions par jour elle tgv
s'arrêter à 35 yémen on a fini qui
aujourd'hui me le reproche qui
aujourd'hui va dire cher christian cette
dépense là il fallait pas le faire parce
que chacun d'entre nous nous devons
porter une vision d'ambition et s'il n'y
a pas d'infrastructures ya pas de vision
n'y a pas d'ambition
parce que qu'on le veuille ou non les
infrastructures c'est le squelette de la
vision taux n'est pas dans le quotidien
pardon dans la proximité dans le sourire
dans la poignée de main dans la tape
dans le dos dans la politique dans tout
ce que j'ai fait toute ma vie mais qui
doit être complétée par une vision et
par une ambition donc le grand paris
doit porter cette ambition on ne doit
pas renier ses ambitions et comme de
surcroît ya les jeux olympiques
quand j'entends dire que certaines
villes seront finis deux ans après les
jeux olympiques
on m'a dit mais pourquoi vous faites
quelque chose un pic alors pardon le
linge moi je suis à fond pour les jeux
olympiques
je suis à fond pour le tour de france
et je suis à fond pour les sapins de
noël bat peut pas être plus des mauvais
mais les jeux olympiques quand la mère
de paris m'a demandé d'aider pour la
candidature je suis pas dit oulala
années socialistes je ne suis pas bien
je l'aimé c'est un événement qui nous
transcende tous allons-y ensemble c'est
une occasion de rencontre c'est une
occasion partage c'est une occasion de
d'ouverture mondiale alors qu'on ne
parle que des oppositions entre les uns
les autres
il faut bien qu'ils aient un événement
qui nous transcende tous c'est le grand
paris aussi chez christian parce que
s'il ya les jeux olympiques en 2024
c'est l'occasion de terminer cette
première partie sans dire un mot du
grand paris patrick et des prêts pas de
se dire on va être prêt deux ans après
alors dans ce cas là c'est pas la peine
de faire venir des millions de gens et
de faire cet événement sans compter que
le retard accroît le coût
enfin et j'y crois beaucoup de même
c'est un sujet très sensible la question
du bo
c'est une question passionnante et on
dit n'importe quoi sur le sujet le beau
c'est subjectif et je le vois bien dans
le regard de ma femme
c'est subjectif
mais c'est pas parce que ses juges
objectifs qu'on n'a pas le droit d'en
parler
est ce que je me fais comprendre or le
beau le bo a disparu du débat public au
profit du légal et du réglementaire
là aussi je prends mes responsabilités
je pense je trouve que le projet de la
tour montparnasse est formidable je n'ai
aucune arrière pensée politique
je dis simplement que augmenté 30 % la
capacité au mètre carré de la tour
montparnasse pour offert une des plus
belles tour du monde ça valait le coup
de maître 30% de mètres carrés en plus
parce que s'il n'y avait pas cette
augmentation de mètres carrés il y
aurait jamais la réflexion nature
montparnasse dire ça c'est pas prendre
parti pour quelqu'un pour quelqu'un
d'autre
c'est simplement posé la question du bo
le bo est subjectif c'est pas pour ça
qu'ils n'existent pas et j'avais voulu
gries york il sait bien que le grand
paris soit d'abord le grand paris des
architectes
moi j'adore architecture gens passionnés
insidieux et l'architecturé c'est
certainement l'un des z'arts le plus
noble qui existe parce qu'il est gratuit
parce qu'il est accessible à tous et
parce que vous voyez
l'architecturé n'ai pas besoin de
rentrer de s'amuser et moi je ne peux
pas supporter l'idée que les gestes
architecturaux majeurs se passe en
dehors de chez nous épluchez donc chaque
fois guerra alors après on peut aimer
pas aimé moi je suis aussi pour la
tuerie lecture triangle à la défense où
est comme ça grave mon cas
mais quelle est la fidélité à son époque
on est fidèle le fleuve est fidèle à sa
sauce en allant vers le maire notre
génération qu'est ce qu'elle va rester
qu'est ce qu'elle va livrer si on n'a
pas un geste architectural qui témoigne
de notre époque
une ambition architecturale et qui on la
fait pas à paris où est ce qu on la fera
donc les architectes le débat passionné
sur la suite et sûrs quand monsieur
mitterrand a fait l'a permis
de paye moi j'ai aimé le débat très
violent à l'époque sur cette pyramide
mais le débat c'est la démocratie ça me
gêne pas moins il y avait des cours il y
avait des comptes
la flèche de notre dame il ya des cours
il ya des contres mais c'est pas gênant
au contraire ça vivifie notre démocratie
qu'est-ce qui évoquait ce qu'il n'est
pas ce que j'aime pas moi c'est les faux
débats alors un ou poser question mais
un jour le journal pour ou contre les
tours ça alors moi je suis pour les
belles tour et je suis cool et je suis
contre les tours qui s'enlève le débat
sur la densité
je vous en supplie de comprendre ça n'a
aucun sens qu'est ce que vous préférez
la densité de manhattan
la densité de l'île saint louis où les
rues vont cap m ou 5 mètres de large où
le mitage qui existent parfois dans les
départements d'outre-mer où est ce que
je veux dire où la ville
à défaut d'avoir été structuré s'étale
partout bourg tous les espaces qui
devrait le laisser à l'agriculture parce
que ce que vous ne donnez pas en densité
vous vous le donnerais en surface donc
c'est absurde de dire il faut des
densifier peut-être dans certains cas
mais partir d'un postulat que la
densification est un péché est une faute
c'est absurde encore une fois quand on
se balade dans les rues de manhattan
est ce qu'il ya quelqu'un qui dit c'est
moche c'est trop dense mais ce qu'il ya
quelqu'un qui dise à personne donc je
voudrais proposer cette idée je pense
que la nouvelle est à atrium tous ceux
qui avaient une responsabilité c'est le
grand paris du logement je voudrais
lancé cette idée là josé ribeaud
pourquoi pas ce qu'on construit mal
parce qu'on construit trop peu et parce
qu'on construit trop cher et je pense
que la deuxième étape du grand paris je
vois bien pourquoi le grand pas la
première étape ça d'abord été l'étape
des transports je n'ai voulu donc je ne
suis pas content mais n'est-ce pas
christian dans notre esprit le grand
paris n'a jamais été uniquement un grand
paris des transports jamais nous n'avons
pensé ça jamais maurice nous l'avons dit
sans transport and c'est vrai patrick
qu'on n'a pas grand paris mais réduire
le grand paris à 65 km ou à 54 km 2 de
transport ça serait une erreur il faut
maintenant se mettre sur le grand paris
du logement vous allez avoir quelque
chose comme 65 nouveaux quartiers avec
toutes les les gares etc
il faut les repenser les restructurer et
pour cela s'imaginer que la
densification en échange de la
réhabilitation de la restructuration et
de la rénovation
c'est le pari gagnant voilà ce que je
pense c'est à dire que vous prenez des
immeubles qu'ils sont laids qui sont en
état de délabrement vous dit au
propriétaire
vous avez le droit on vous donnera le
droit de construire davantage qui fera
des logements pour les gens mais en
échange on veut une ambition
architecturale qui peut être contre ça
mais c'est ça le grand paris et à ce
moment là vous aurez réussi la ville
nouvelle parce que c'est en me dis à
quelqu'un qui est qu'est ce que c'est
qu'une ville heureuse
j'en sais rien il ya des tas de ville
que j'aime
elles sont différentes il s'agit pas de
faire le bond de singapour sur la scène
où le bond de shanghai sur la marne
ça n'a aucun sens mais ce grand pari du
logement c'est me semble-t-il une façon
pour la population de s'approprier le
grand paris enfin parce que je peux être
trop long et je veux pas passer votre
patience qui gère le grand
paris et comment on fait dans mon esprit
les choses sont très claires
le grand paris n'a une chance de réussir
que si le président de la république lui
même si mais je ne dis pas ça parce que
c'est monsieur macron ou parce que
c'était moi hier ou demain qui vous
voulez si le président de la république
ne fait pas peut-être futur président
puis dans un sens on ne sait jamais
d'ailleurs ce serait curieux contenu
toutes les ambitions qui n'est pas ici
je me serais trompé en venant ici ce
matin
bon je suis déçu dans ça veut donc dire
qu'on fait parler devant des gens qui
manquent d'ambition pas des dents vous
êtes rares bon si le président la
république ne s'y met pas lui même n'en
fait pas lui même son projet c'est très
difficile de réussir parce que dans le
système institutionnel français et c'est
pas du tout que il faut passer au-dessus
des élus patrick j'ai été élu toute ma
vie donc je ne peux pas dire du mal des
élus je respecte les élus et pour moi
quelqu'un qui s'engage c'est toujours
mieux que quelqu'un qui reste sur
l'aventin mais la période de conception
de réalisation du grand paris ou du
grand lyon du grand marseille c'est
l'état et l'état dans l'expression
suprême le président républicain moi
j'avais choisi des ministres très bon
choix d'ailleurs mais derrière c'est pas
faire insulte région à maurice de dire
que j'étais là à chaque seconde entre
vent que ça allait passer dès qu'il
fallait plus vite ils veulent plus
ambitions sinon ça ne peut pas marcher
alors ensuite et j'ai toujours refusé et
je les ai d'ailleurs dit à monsieur
macron le mécano institutions
pourquoi parce que c'était la meilleure
façon d'en lisez les choses car
naturellement qu'on peut pas passer au
dessus du maire de paris que
naturellement quelle région ile de
france qui voulait dire ce mot que
naturellement il ya toutes les communes
de la petite de la grande couronne et
les autres puisque dans mon esprit le
grand paris va au delà des limites de
régions de france
mais si vous commencez à trancher dans
ce millefeuille avant d'avoir réalisé
vous arrêter le système parce que chacun
a une possibilité de bloquer même si
personne n'a la possibilité faire
avancer nos qu'une fois que les invite
les infrastructures du grand paris sont
réalisés
la question qui va se poser les très
simple qui paye et je vais vous dire
celui qui paiera décidera c'est aussi
simple que ça et d'ailleurs faut-il
s'éteint pas avec violence que y ait
qu'une seule personne qui décide pour
tous aucune seule collectivité qui paye
pas du tout tant qu'on construit on
continue le système qui a été trouvé qui
est pas si mal une fois que les
infrastructures sont livrés on décide au
cas par cas
quelle est la collectivité quelle est la
personnalité qui est la plus légitime ou
qui est la plus à même de payer et de
diriger et ainsi vous aurez résolu le
problème
pourquoi trancher cette question de qui
va gérer une infrastructure qui ne sera
prêt que dans dix ans c'est curieux ça
amène quoi ça donne quoi
du temps perdu des polémiques et la
désespérance d'une population qui n'ont
peu plus parce que ça n'avance pas voilà
profondément ce que je pense
suis désolé d'avoir été trop long est
certainement d'avoir là c'est votre
attention
mais je termine avec ça le grand paris
c'est une façon d'aimer la france si on
aime notre pays on a de l'ambition pour
lui avoir l'ambition pour le grand paris
cerveau de l'ambition pour la france et
je vois bien tourner dans la proximité
la protection de l'environnement
le jeu n'est pas dire être normal parce
que ça on a vu ce que ça donnait enfin
être est ce un sens oui on a vu celle
banc mais en assurant la promotion de
grands projets on éloigne pas les gens
de vous les politiques
moi ya pas plus éloigné de moi que les
comités tirés au sort
szavay
prenez l'avion ce qui reste
et par souci démocratique et pour être
dans le coup on va tirer au sort celui
des passagers qui va piloter va à
l'hôpital en tire au sort celui qui va
vous opérer moi je crois à la démocratie
aux élus si vous n'êtes pas content de
vos élus voulaient changer à la
prochaine élection mais tant qu'on est
en démocratie c'est les élus que vous
avez choisi pour qui vous avez voté qui
ont la légitimité pour décider et pour
assumer leurs responsabilités et
l'ambition merci de m'avoir donné
l'occasion par exemple
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]